okay yeah [ __ ] batches okay we're like
a [ __ ] SSO boys heckle battle
okay and we're gonna plays I'm are shut
I get it we're gonna play some more prep
all right yeah kind of bad bye
[ __ ] I just got a text oh it's one of my
fans
[Music]
okay bye Jessica Rogers
we're gonna add up a chest we're going
out of their chest okay okay um it's
getting [ __ ] tough okay we're in a
[ __ ] crew quarters and a desk at a
tough okay
what the [ __ ] do I gonna do now I got a
check and we got to kill the cop that's
what we got to do and apparently it look
a lot and the cook is [ __ ] hiding in
well what was that [ __ ] noise oh I
say huh oh I got that Suri psycho em
okay uh can we see it why check tubes
are and you can okay I got to go to the
Arboretum and kill the imposter [ __ ] got
a deep storage got a deep storage I
could just [ __ ] leave but puck that
and search the cargo bay put the secret
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] to do that we'll do
this for now
I'm very held up though okay let me just
tell you that that shut
isn't there a where the [ __ ] is okay I
would like okay all right now
I hope the Arboretum to get like two
grazing so it's gone
I think they're a [ __ ] how many
Coptics turns everywhere so you know if
it does get like crazy I think we okay
okay and okay okay may pass a good
afternoon talent that safety of or
talents one is everyone's responsibility
[ __ ] at all have requested some
talents to security at transpose data
how is that
I haven't eaten peoples right now I
don't I guess I cut its [ __ ] side nap
oh where is it
oh [ __ ] what's that fun she said so what
the [ __ ] happened in this place
how the [ __ ] is it said oh [ __ ]
close the door I say ya betch
holy [ __ ] this place is gone to the dogs
what is that a mimic look at it it's so
stupid
um try to figure out what I should do
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay I guess I'm gonna
have to quick save here get in here
[ __ ] yeah you like that [ __ ] I want to
pick a trap this [ __ ] in here okay I
guess we're gonna have to try it
hello [ __ ]
now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] how do you close a
dark eddy close the door close it dark
what the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
very sad
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] where's the
nightmare I say it [ __ ] I say yeah [ __ ]
what is that required oh [ __ ] that would
hurt me can I shoot them through here
[ __ ] it's not just [ __ ] wasting ammo
at home quick load I could use that
recycler charge on him get up again
get up [ __ ] okay
okay here we got matches get up get up
get up
okay we got one okay we got to you BAE
this [ __ ]
over there I need a keycard or can I
just [ __ ] go at it and once you think
get this guy to go a little closer [ __ ]
now is that no whip do okay okay hey hey
[Music]
[ __ ] your name is annoying
she's huge how many food right kid I get
some beefs takes yeah it's a my vase
that was and let me dump some of these
bad boys and I'm trying to say it okay I
made it less I'm sorry guys I'm sorry I
- Dennis wait we [ __ ] quick look I get
I had a lot more help
all right betcha so you come on I slack
okay being a little [ __ ] he's been a
little [ __ ] comebacks and I came to
come over here what if I shoot like a
single parole on it okay here we go
HS let me just get some scope on him
there we go come on rich
quark
like I said so what happens where did he
go after one minute is he socket
disappear let's make sure the objective
real quick
hello cap how [ __ ] that hurt me please
[ __ ] a lathe
are you [ __ ] laughing
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] scary [ __ ] let's
look at this little [ __ ] right there
you know [ __ ] Gretch I say yo you
[ __ ] hairy [ __ ] stuck in here
getting a nice in here
not nothing I should block up that
[ __ ] hole now that's 12 seconds five
seconds
come on come on
nice nice lie down betcha
holy [ __ ] like I put a cycling tour down
there I get in that does not
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
which way do I go which way do I go this
way oh yeah now what's the [ __ ] is it
where you take the set up with our
brooms who crazy
the [ __ ] is that noise how would that do
zero points sigh Oh a nice tooth [ __ ]
up
ok sit up great can't hear a [ __ ] and a
DA say a [ __ ]
anything in here
the [ __ ] is that what is that
oh [ __ ] ah yes again hell a fact I can
only 9-0 medical console ladies of the
form of diagnosing you look like you let
a rough day I'll have your feet I didn't
have our rap - questionnaire okay plays
out of the way sir
okay I'll check this [ __ ] map whoo I
have a way to go operate a dispenser
[ __ ] and that was the way I really
didn't want to go up
her [ __ ] run [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so [ __ ] she'll just the sons of
[ __ ] they began you're just a bunch
of sons of [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] are they
going down there
cannot tell Anna oh oh shut up yet
[ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] my ass out baby
about my [ __ ] by banks yeah yeah
[Music]
Alex Oedipus complex pompous nepotistic
going into that tape storage babe yeah
yeah yeah sorry gonna have to lock you
in the sky you're down fire treasure
arming key it was to keep you from
making a huge mistake it's too late to
stick our heads in the sand we're
committed now
your shirt's be safe in deep storage
when everything is ready we'll meet in
my office I hope you believe me
I really am on your side just not
yourself yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] welcome to deep storage if
Dallas one had a subconscious this would
be it you're looking for the central
repository that's where you stash the
drive that has a plan for your army I'll
see if I can find a way out of here in
the meantime ya [ __ ] bag
where are you sucks out there okay
anyways files no chance for that hey
Mouse
check out alright one eight seven zero
Wow like that I guess
top nine in my brain I see alright and
fill this gene is coming closer maybe it
is what you see I'm hungry I'm always
hungry I will wait in you you will come
out so let's go nowhere to go hey get
[ __ ] up let me see what's down there
transform : 14 engineering culture
every dark bit of data that moves
through the station's captured here
redundant backup servers are stored in
module only sad failure the fact that
they haven't yet is telling of Alex's
refusal to face reality always [ __ ] my
ass home [ __ ] my ass home
oh [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
shet any [ __ ] service parts oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] no [ __ ] he's right there okay
pictures now thousand side
holy [ __ ] have to get my tip wet
yeah [ __ ] bet
your [ __ ] heart
oh oh oh
it hurts it hurts it hurts baby yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] and you [ __ ] in
there now out out
[Applause]
attention yeah [ __ ] bets yeah you
like that [ __ ] I gotta I gotta take my
heal myself don't need this don't I have
like anti rad now what is that I always
have my entire rap did I [ __ ] get rid
of it I almost [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm just a [ __ ] fat ass baby yet I'm
just a [ __ ] thank you buddy that get
rid of that baby
requesting new operator Transtar cobalt
410 engineering class operator ready to
deploy nice and clear
exactly that's all okay
yeah what sauce another checked in here
where's you have the one that's up there
hello how do I get up there
the [ __ ] stairs or am I just a town
[Music]
what the [ __ ] you go eat this [ __ ]
went up you guys have to figure out a
way to get upwards caution center
gravity
unseal the doors [ __ ] [ __ ] when I
sock that [ __ ] John okay let me see
here let me see let me think for a
second okay
and I think for a while to have second
Roger that real quick there a way to get
rid of that okay well I got to go upward
that's for sure
so [ __ ] it
and
[ __ ] you ivy
what is that so on second alright I
gotta go guys bye